Why isn't Obi-Wan Kenobi pulling out his lightsaber?
Where is this missing inquisitor?
And did anyone notice the new adorable droid?
These are the details they slipped by you
in the second Obi-Wan Kenobi trailer.
The new trailer marks the first glimpse of
comedy actor Kumail Nanjiani.
And if his wardrobe is anything to go by,
the Force might be with him too.
Nanjiani can be seen hunkered down, seemingly
in hiding.
Interestingly, his character, who has yet
to be named, is wearing threads similar to
the now eradicated Jedi.
Might Nanjiani's character be one of the few,
like Obi-Wan Kenobi, that escaped the fallout
from Order 66?
If so, being the last remnant of the ancient
order is no laughing matter.
This series could mark the actor taking on
a more serious and less quippy role than his
fans are used to — and it may spell doom
for his character's fate, given the risks
of being a Jedi in this scary post-"Revenge
of the Sith" world.
The highly anticipated reunion between Obi-Wan
and Darth Vader is not the only obstacle the
Jedi Knight will have to face in the new series.
Fans of "Star Wars: Rebels" will recognize
the Inquisitors' return to the "Star Wars"
narrative.
Many Inquisitors had once been Jedi themselves,
but after Order 66, they joined the Empire,
and used their force sensitivity to hunt down
the remaining Jedi and other threats to the Empire.
"The Jedi knights are all but destroyed and
yet your task is not complete, Inquisitor."
Though Inquisitors are featured heavily in
the "Obi-Wan Kenobi" trailer, there is one
character who is missing.
Seventh Sister was a main antagonist in the
animated series, but she is nowhere to be
seen in the new trailer.
Considering the inclusion of both the High
Inquisitor and Fifth Brother who both appeared
in "Rebels," this omission may seem odd.
Many fans on Reddit have commented on their
hope to see an appearance of the character.
However, there is some logic to her absence.
When Ezra first encounters her in "Rebels,"
Seventh Sister has a specific mission.
Many of the Inquisitors are trying to kidnap
force sensitive children but Seventh Sister
is also on the hunt for Anakin's former padawan,
Ahsoka Tano.
This could explain Seventh Sister's absence
in the events of "Obi-Wan Kenobi."
It might indicate that she'll instead be appearing
in the Ahsoka Tano Disney+ series.
While Kylo Ren's fiery lightsaber design in
the sequel trilogy is definitely one for the
books, "Star Wars" die-hards know that there's
no characters who play with lightsaber construction
more creatively than the Inquisitors.
The Grand Inquisitor's lightsaber has a circular
motor of some sort surrounding its handle,
allowing the lightsaber to rotate like a helicopter's
blades.
It seems that Inquisitor Reva's lightsaber
may serve a similar function — as shots
of her using her weapon in the trailer show
a similar half-circle handle guard of some
kind extending from one end of the lightsaber's
handle.
Given the way actress Moses Ingram and the
series' executive producers have hyped up
the character in recent months, expect it
to be used to help make Reva a uniquely terrifying villain.
"Obi-Wan Kenobi" series writer and executive
producer Joby Harold recently told Entertainment
Weekly that Reva's addition to the franchise
will be a touchstone point in the history
of Star Wars bad guys.
Ingram, for her part, described the character
as athletic and driven toward completing her
mission: it doesn't appear unreasonable to
think Reva may be the one to truly give Kenobi
a tough time throughout the series.
Another new "Star Wars" project, another cute
droid to merchandise, another toy to add to
your collection.
This brand-new droid has an interesting red-and-white
design with flaps on its back end that almost
appear to move like ears.
Between the red color scheme and black gloved
hand that it appears in, it seems safe to
assume this droid belongs to one of the Inquisitors,
if not Reva herself.
Throughout nine "Star Wars" films, multiple
Disney+ live-action series, and any number
of animated shows Lucasfilms has produced
over the years, we've seen droids do everything
from repairing pod racers to piloting ships
to scouting out enemies — surely this one
will serve a unique purpose toward the galaxy-wide
search for Kenobi.
If the new droid looks slightly familiar,
it may be due to the fact that it somewhat
resembles the very top of a BB unit without
the ball underneath that it rolls under — the
noises it makes certainly don't fall too far
from how BB-8 sounds throughout the three
most recent "Star Wars" movies.
Those take place decades after the new "Obi-Wan
Kenobi" series, though: perhaps this droid
design is a precursor to the lovable rolling
ball that accompanies Poe Dameron throughout
the galaxy in the sequel trilogy.
Between this trailer and the first hair-raising
teaser we got a few weeks back, one thing
that both previews are missing is something
no Jedi should be without, and that's a lightsaber
— Obi-Wan's, to be exact.
While Anakin Skywalker's former master looks
to be getting into plenty of trouble in the
new trailer, he's keeping most threats at
bay thanks to having a trusty blaster at his side.
"So uncivilized."
This begs the question — what is going on?
Given that Kenobi is undoubtedly trying to
stay out of sight of the Empire, it's definitely
true that firing up his lightsaber might not
be the smartest move.
Is there a chance that
there's more to it than that?
The last time we saw Kenobi sheath his weapon,
he'd left Anakin screaming in agony on the
shores of Mustafar, and watched the collapse
of everything he'd spent his life fighting for.
Did the infamous duel have a lasting effect
on the old Jedi Knight, making him reluctant
to draw arms again?
Could the teased reunion between master and
former apprentice cause old friends to draw
swords once again?
It might just happen if our hero is forced
to do so.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Star Wars shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.